c'est jacques bonjour alors est ce que
c'est un nouveau
c'est de la peinture on ne sait plus
très bien quand on fait une première
visite en tout cas c'est tout
c'est un jeu c'est une aventure
yana jeu qui se déroule ici samuel une
aventure
il ya combien de temps pour travailler
sur ce projet trois bris
deux ans deux ans et la première fois
vous allez me fait attendre
e
la chasse
alors justement est-ce que c'est dans la
lignée de la chasse au trésor par
exemple des grands jeux pourrait déjà
fait dans la lignée des grands jeux
mentionnait les jeunes aventures mais ça
n'a rien
alors c'est une grande aventure on va
pas dévoiler les secrets on n'a pas
montré ce qu'est le jeu on va attendre
toutefois sur l'antenne
combien de personnes travaillent ici à
fort boyard là ils veulent avoir un peu
d'indicateurs
60 70 par moment du tournage centaines
une centaine de personnes alors dans
quelques jours
ce sera là la première de
fabuleuse émission on peut dire que
c'est une première mondiale quasiment
jamais on a mis autant de moyens sa mère
le mi automne moyens je la fais des
choses aussi généralement la télévision
c'est nude et pas raconter sa vie
alors on fait aussi de la télévision
bien sûr de les voir une infrastructure
technique considérable parce qu'on peut
avoir imité dix sept caméras 17 caméras
voilà il nous en faut une un reportage
et il y en a 17 12 km de câbles oui 12
km de câbles de caméras
e il a fallu tout péter
système réalisation originaux tout à
fait
tiens
par radio des cafés dias les caméras
de quoi on a peur avant une première
aussi grandiose de tous notamment
d'avoir oublié le salut passait comme ça
en fait on a peur d'avoir oublié
je ne sais pas ce qu'on va mouiller on
va sûrement oublié quelque chose au
dernier moment qu'ils sont une
catastrophe
il faudra toute vitesse retournez à la
côte pour chercher plutôt sans oublier
l'ennui ce cas aussi à des vagues
remettra pas quart d'heure pour
descendre du bateau
six heures pour aller faire nos preuves
et trois quarts d'heure pour remonter
c'est une scène il peut pas cher